[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER 1: Brian Patrick Eha
is going to get us started.
He is a journalist who's
followed the rise of Bitcoin
from its beginnings.
His work has appeared
in "The New Yorker",
in "The Atlantic", "CNN Money",
"Entrepreneur", "Outside",
and the "LA Review of Books."
He's the author of
the new book, "How
Money Got Free,
Bitcoin and the Fight
for the Future of Finance."
And we'll have copies of
the book available for sales
and signing after the event.
All right, Brian, do you want to
come up and get things started?
We can give him a round.
[APPLAUSE]
BRIAN PATRICK EHA: All right,
thanks for being here, guys.
I'm Brian.
I think I'm going to
keep this fairly short,
because I know the
real substance of this
is going to come in the Q&A,
first with Tessa and then
when I get to hear
whatever questions you
might have for me.
But I thought it
would be good maybe
to talk first about how I
got into Bitcoin, writing
about it as a journalist.
So I first heard
about Bitcoin in 2011,
but I didn't know anybody
in the space at the time.
I wasn't really thinking
of writing about it
as a journalistic subject.
Then in the summer of 2012, I
was working as a staff writer
at "CNN Money", and
some news appeared,
this little news item
appeared on "Hacker News".
Something had leaked
out of a Bitcoin startup
that was based here in the
Flatiron district in New York.
I didn't even know
they were there,
but it sounded kind
of interesting.
They were trying to
do this debit card
that you could load with
Bitcoin and then use it
like a normal debit card.
So there'd be a way for you
to spend your digital currency
in the real world.
I pitched this story to my
editor, and I'll never forget.
When I pitched it, she said,
yeah, OK, go and do it.
But don't make it out
to be more than it is.
Bitcoin is just a play
thing for crypto anarchists.
It's this weird kind of
artifact of internet culture,
but it's nothing, you know?
It's fairy dust.
It's tulips, it's whatever.
I didn't really see it that way.
But I also didn't
have the ammunition
to argue against
her at the time.
So I just kind of said, OK,
and I went and did this story.
But as I went and did the
story, I talked to these guys
in their offices and
actually it turned out
that some other blogs
had picked up the news
item from "Hacker News."
But I was the only one
who actually went and met
with these guys and tried
to dig into the real story.
I remember just being blown away
as I talked to them with what
they were doing.
They were young, they were
hungry, they were passionate.
They were these kind
of Mark Zuckerberg
move fast and break
stuff kind of guys.
I was just astonished by
how they were sacrificing
everything to try to build
the early infrastructure
of a new economy.
I became convinced that
Bitcoin had real potential
and could potentially
change the world.
In fact, the CEO of
that startup ended up
becoming one of the main
characters in my book.
Back then, the price of a
single Bitcoin, I remember,
was less than $10 and the value
of all Bitcoins in existence
was only $96 million.
Today, even with some
recent price drops,
I think the value of a
Bitcoin is about $2,400
and the market cap is somewhere
in the tens of billions
of dollars.
So I think I made the right
choice to take it seriously.
OK, but what is Bitcoin?
How does it work?
What makes it worth
anything at all?
Well in the simplest
terms, Bitcoin
is a form of commodity money.
When it was first
created in January 2009,
its original promise was to
be a truly universal currency,
a form of electronic
cash that could be sent
around the globe in minutes.
That would work just
as well in New York
as it did in New Delhi.
Transactions were anonymous, or
at least were supposed to be,
and it all happened on a network
that existed independently
of any government or bank.
The interesting thing to me
when I first heard about Bitcoin
was I knew that early internet
pioneers had always envisioned
that a payment's
protocol would be woven
into the fabric of the web.
You've got a guy like Peter
Thiel who came a bit later.
When he was building PayPal,
his original ambition
was to create an
internet currency that
would replace the US dollar
for online transactions.
What kept him from doing
that was not actually
the popping of the
dot com bubble,
it was 9/11 and the raft of
new financial regulations
that came down in the wake
of the terrorist attacks.
They forced him to
pivot away from that.
Because otherwise
PayPal would have
been accused of money laundering
and all sorts of other things.
So the brilliant thing that
Satoshi Nakamoto, the creator
of Bitcoin, did is he
didn't found a new company
like PayPal.
Instead, he built a
decentralized system
that no one would own, but
anyone could participate in.
You'd have this
constantly updated copy
of the ledger recording
all the transactions that
would be stored on
the computer of anyone
on the network, anyone
running the open source
software of Bitcoin.
So it started out as the
money of the internet.
But gradually as
people began to think
about its underlying technology
and take a closer look at it,
they began to refer to it
as the internet of money.
The technology
underlying Bitcoin
is called the blockchain.
It's basically a
tamper proof ledger
for recording and
verifying transactions,
which admittedly sounds like the
least sexy thing in the world.
But the revolutionary
thing about it
is that it allows
for transactions
to be recorded and
verified without the need
for a central authority.
So normally that would be a
payments company like PayPal
or it would be a bank or
it would be a government
or it would be some
combination of the two
like the Federal Reserve.
But businesses and services
of blockchain technology
can be decentralized, which
simultaneously cuts out
middlemen that add
cost to the system,
and it removes any
single points of failure
in the system at the same time.
This is disruptive to
a lot of businesses.
One of the interesting things
when I was working on my book
was to dig into the
international financial system
and find out just where
Bitcoin could be most useful.
One of the biggest
areas I discovered
was cross-border payments.
So basically the
way it works today,
when banks want to send
money across borders,
they use what's called the
corresponding banking system.
A payment might have to make
as many as five different hops
to get to where it's
ultimately going across all
of these different
financial institutions
and be exchanged from
one currency to another.
Typically when a bank
wants to send money
to another bank across
borders, it first
has to be holding cash at
that other institution.
This cash is just
kind of dormant.
It's dead cash that just
sits there waiting until they
need to make payments with it.
This is hugely wasteful.
That cash isn't doing
anything for them
until they have to
make the payments.
Then on the consumer level,
you have remittances.
This is when immigrants want to
send money back to their loved
ones in their home countries.
They usually use Western
Union or MoneyGram today,
and they get charged
really high fees.
So migrants from Sub-Saharan
Africa, for instance,
pay an average of 9.81%
when they send money home.
The global average is 7.45%,
which itself is really high.
But you might notice there
that often the poorest
and the people that
are suffering the most
have to end up paying
the highest fees.
Well, remittances are a
$600 billion market today.
The idea is that Bitcoin or
maybe another digital currency
that surpasses it has a chance
to grab a piece of that market
while putting
billions of dollars
back into people's pockets.
Today in fact there's a
venture backed company called
Abra, which is doing just that.
It's using Bitcoin to
provide cheaper remittances
to more than 100 countries.
But what people realized
was that the things
you store and transmit
on a blockchain
doesn't have to be money.
So one of the first
guys to realize this
was the venture capitalist,
Marc Andreessen.
He wrote an op ed for
"The New York Times"
way back in January 2014
in which he called Bitcoin
not a digital currency,
not a form of money.
He called it a digital
bearer instrument,
a way of exchanging assets
and confirming their ownership
over the internet.
Those assets could be
digital currency, of course.
They could be the titles and
deeds to physical property.
They could be stocks and bonds.
They could be a number
of different assets.
So this is the reason the
world's biggest banks and tech
companies are all setting
up blockchain labs
and working groups and
building proofs of concept.
This is the reason Bitcoin and
blockchain startups have raised
something like $1.6
billion of investment
capital in the past few years.
Their investors
include names you
might know, like GV,
Goldman Sachs, Visa,
Capital One, NASDAQ, and
The New York Stock Exchange.
Now if that isn't enough,
the interesting thing
also is that Bitcoin has
actually inspired people
to create other crypto
currencies, some of which
have features that arguably
make them superior to Bitcoin.
Then even more than that,
many of the hottest blockchain
assets today are not
digital currencies at all.
They're these things
called tokens.
They don't have blockchain
networks of their own
to run on.
Instead, they run on top of an
existing blockchain network,
such as Bitcoins or Ethereums.
They tend to be purpose built
for specific applications.
So there's one
called Golem which
is meant to power a peer to peer
marketplace for computation.
There's one called
Augur, which is
for a crowdsourced
prediction market and so on.
Dozens of these tokens
have launched so far.
Some of you have probably
seen the headlines.
They've been raising
huge amounts of capital
in unbelievably short
amounts of time.
One raised $10
million in six hours.
Then another raised $35
million in 30 seconds.
Another raised $150
million in an hour or two.
The amount raised now for
these software projects
through this new token
model has actually
surpassed the amount
of money that's
been put in by
traditional venture
capitalists into this
industry so far this year.
That itself is
over $200 million,
so it's nothing to sneeze at.
So dozens of these tokens
have been launched,
and dozens more
are on the horizon.
People are starting
to think this
might yield the second
business model of the internet.
To see why, I think
it helps to think
about what the current
business model is, right?
So take Facebook.
If Facebook had issued
a token to its users,
its value, we could
imagine, would
derive from the
content and connections
that are generated on Facebook.
Now, early users, when it was
just restricted to college
students-- there weren't
many people on there--
they might have been
able to kind of scoop up
a large number of these
tokens at cheap prices.
Then later users who kind of
jumped on the bandwagon later
as the value of the
platform became apparent,
maybe they'd only be
able to afford a few.
But all of them, by holding
this liquid digital asset,
would be able to participate
in Facebook's growing success.
That, of course, is not how
Facebook operates, right?
We know that the $450
billion value of Facebook
accrues mainly to
Mark Zuckerberg
and the other shareholders.
Most other internet
platforms operate
in a similar way, Twitter,
Tumblr, Instagram, even Etsy.
The owners of these
platforms are not actually
producing content themselves,
but they extract massive value
from the interactions
between users.
This has become so
common and so accepted
that it's actually
difficult to imagine
a different kind of setup.
With decentralized systems
based on blockchain tokens,
though, there's no longer
a division or no longer
such a clear division at least
between the users and owners.
The tokens become a
wealth sharing mechanism,
which is a way that everyone,
even the average consumers,
the average users,
can get a piece
of the future of the internet.
So the token is kind
of a unit of account
that prices users back in.
It doesn't even end there.
In a couple of years
I'm told we can
expect to see something
called [? perichains. ?]
Think of it as a kind
of connective glue
that would allow all the
different blockchain networks
to communicate with each other.
So right now they're isolated,
but with [? perichains, ?]
applications and smart
contracts built on one system
would be able to
interact with the assets
and data on the other systems.
So users could flow easily from
one to the next to the next,
strengthening the
whole ecosystem.
As long as you're keyed
into any cryptocurrency,
you'd have access to
every cryptocurrency.
Because of this, the
CEO of a hedge fund
recently told me that he expects
in 10 years the total market
cap of all blockchain assets
will be at least $1 trillion.
The last thing I want to say
is that the effects of Bitcoin
and blockchain technology
won't be felt only
on the internet or only
in the realm of finance.
I think Bitcoin
actually represents
a counterforce to some of
the most troubling trends
of our time, which is the
rising tide of nationalism,
populism, trade protectionism,
and all of this stuff
that we're seeing in the US,
the UK, and across Europe.
So until 2016, I
think for many of us
the world appeared to be moving
inexorably toward open borders,
economic inclusion, closer
alliances between nations,
right?
The narrative was that our
global citizenry was rejecting
the old prejudice of
nationalism and tribalism,
and history was describing a
more and more wonderful arc.
Well, then we had Brexit, right?
Then we had the
election of Donald Trump
and we have the refugee crisis.
That kind of changed
our way of thinking.
But there is still another story
happening at the same time.
I think it's one that many
of us are participating in.
It's about how the way
that people live and work
is changing.
It's about the fact that
international travel
is easier than ever, the fact
that technologies like Skype
have expanded our reach, the
fact that a lot of young people
today see themselves more
as citizens of the world
or of some internet
subculture than they
do their countries of origin.
So the time really is ripe for
a universal digital currency
and for the other technologies
that it makes possible.
Bitcoin is that currency, or
is at least the first version
of that currency.
I noticed while writing my
book, and it's still true today,
that very few Bitcoin or
blockchain startups are focused
only on developing nations.
That's to be expected, right?
Because cryptocurrency is a
tool of international inclusion.
Its advocates tend
to be committed
to open borders and
the free flow of people
and ideas and capital.
Naval Ravikant, the CEO of
AngelList, one of the smartest
guys in Silicon Valley,
he recently said
that Bitcoin is a tool
for freeing humanity
from oligarchs and
tyrants dressed up as a
get rich quick scheme.
So I guess the last
thought to leave you with
is that Bitcoin has implications
not just for finance
and commerce, but for
politics, digital privacy, law
enforcement, even citizenship.
Its story opens a
window onto some
of the most important
issues of our time.
Hopefully we'll get to
discuss a few of those now.
Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER 1: All right.
We can transition over here.
BRIAN PATRICK EHA: No, I know.
SPEAKER 1: All right.
Now everyone keep me honest.
So at 2:35, please start
lining up at these microphones
'cause I'm going to
take your questions.
I have a clock here.
But keep me honest,
and line up, please.
OK, thank you.
BRIAN PATRICK EHA: Sure.
SPEAKER 1: So I wanted
to talk a little bit more
about how bitcoins are made.
And you use this word "mining."
BRIAN PATRICK EHA: Mm.
SPEAKER 1: Can you talk a
little bit about the process?
BRIAN PATRICK EHA: Boy,
that's kind of deep water.
You sure you want
to jump in there?
SPEAKER 1: Mm, high
level, high level.
BRIAN PATRICK EHA: Yeah, so
basically, one of the reasons
that before bitcoin
no one had ever been
able to create workable
electronic cash was
that electronic files can be
copied ad infinitum, right?
I send a Word document to you.
A copy still remains
on my computer.
So if I have electronic
money on my laptop,
and I send it to
you to spend it,
but I get to keep it
on my own computer,
right, just like any
other electronic data,
so this is what's known as
the double spending problem.
And one of the ways that
Satoshi was able to solve that
was through what seems at
first like a counter-intuitive
network that was set up.
But he basically made
the people who are--
he made the people who are
verifying the transactions,
they have to apply
the processing
power of their computers in
order to confirm and verify
those transactions.
And in return for
doing that, they
are then rewarded
with new bitcoins.
So it's kind of a clearinghouse
and a central mint all in one.
But it's not a central mint.
It's decentralized.
SPEAKER 1: But-- sorry,
just to interrupt.
BRIAN PATRICK EHA: Yeah, sure.
SPEAKER 1: These aren't just
your average computers, right?
Like, what kind of
computing power are you--
BRIAN PATRICK EHA: Well, in
the early days they were.
So early on you could just
do it with your laptop.
But what's built
into the system is
that over time, the mathematical
calculations, the numbers
you have to crunch in order to
confirm transactions and create
new bitcoins, they
become harder with time
in order to keep
up with Moore's law
because obviously computers
are a lot more powerful now
than they were in 2009.
And then on top of that, it
was written into the software
that the more processing
power that's applied,
the more difficult
they will become.
So they would become more
difficult over time anyway.
And then also the
more people that get
involved and try to do this,
the more difficult it becomes.
So at first, when there
were only a few people,
you could do it with your GPU--
or with your CPU, sorry.
Then it became a
little more difficult.
People started
using their GPUs--
their graphics
processors-- to do this.
Then even that
became insufficient.
And people started
building ASICs,
which are these
application-specific
processors, just
to mine bitcoins.
And then that turned
into an arms race.
And now you have what are
called mining pools, which
are basically people
with incredibly powerful,
sophisticated machines--
not even terribly
sophisticated, frankly,
but just very powerful.
And they're all pooling their
computer resources together.
And then they kind of
share in the rewards
because it's a race to
confirm the transactions
and then get the bitcoins
every 10 minutes.
SPEAKER 1: Mm-hm.
BRIAN PATRICK EHA:
And as a result,
you want as much processing
power on your side as possible
to try to increase your
chances of-- yeah--
SPEAKER 1: Oh, OK, great.
BRIAN PATRICK EHA: --of
getting the currency.
SPEAKER 1: And one
of my favorite parts
about this book--
and I really do
recommend it-- is all
these amazing stories.
And it doesn't seem
like real life.
It seems, like, very cinematic.
But one of my favorite
ones was about Silk Road.
Do you want to just--
BRIAN PATRICK EHA: Oh, sure.
SPEAKER 1: --set the scene,
talk about the power players,
and the lessons
learned afterwards?
BRIAN PATRICK EHA:
So it's interesting
because a lot of people want to
think of Silk Road as very much
in the past.
And in a sense, it is.
For those who don't know--
I'm sure most of you do--
Silk Road was this underground
black market only accessible
through the Tor
anonymizing software.
And bitcoins were the only
form of money accepted
on this underground market.
And most of what was
bought and sold--
not everything on the
market was illegal.
But most of what was
bought and sold on there
was illegal drugs--
illicit narcotics.
And the impact of Silk
Road really on bitcoin
can't be overestimated.
It started in January of 2011.
I mentioned bitcoin
started in January of 2009.
For the first two
years of its existence,
bitcoin was almost
worthless, I mean,
in terms of monetary value.
The first real transaction
we know of with bitcoins
happened on May 22, 2010.
Someone spent like
25,000 bitcoins
to get somebody
in another country
to order him a couple of
Dominoes pizzas online.
I mean, 25,000 bitcoins
today is like [CHUCKLES]
unbelievable--
millions of dollars.
SPEAKER 1: Oh my god.
BRIAN PATRICK EHA:
But that was just
a kind of proof of concept,
like, yeah, all right,
it works.
You can do this.
But nobody was really doing it.
Well, Silk Road launched.
And they said for
anonymity, privacy reasons,
we're only going
to accept bitcoin.
Within a very short
amount of time--
I mean, just days--
the price of one bitcoin
had reached parity
with the US dollar
and has actually
never fallen below it since.
I mean, as much as the
price has fluctuated,
it's always had real
worth since then.
It's never gone below $1.
And so, yeah, I mean,
in the early days,
Silk Road really
formed a huge part
of the actual total
bitcoin economy.
And then a couple of copycat
markets started springing up.
And they contributed
to it as well.
But by the time
Silk Road shut down
in October of 2013, what
people eventually realized
was, oh, actually bitcoin
can survive without this.
It doesn't rely entirely just
on this underground criminal
economy.
A lot of people had
thought, well, that's it,
Silk Road's gone.
Bitcoin's going to die.
That's all it was used for.
In many people's minds--
those who knew about
bitcoin in those days-- that
was all it was was this
kind of criminal currency.
And it turned out
not to be the case.
At the same time, though,
the criminal use case for it
has not gone away either.
There are still a number of
these markets that exist today.
And people are still using them.
But I think I talked to
a researcher recently
who said it's like, I think,
a $500 million-a-year business
or market he estimated,
which is large.
But when you think of bitcoin's
total market cap and the fact
that billions of
dollars of bitcoins
are trading hands every
day pretty much now,
it's really not such a
big percentage, yeah.
SPEAKER 1: Great.
And for the average person,
if I were, just today, I
wanted to start using bitcoin,
how do I start that process?
How do you go about
getting a wallet?
And I think that it's great
because big banks are not
involved.
But the price of
that is that you
are responsible for
your own protection.
And so what measures
can the average person
take to make sure
that their money won't
get stolen by hackers?
BRIAN PATRICK EHA:
Well, there actually
are some services that will
keep your money for you
if you want it.
And they range from the
unreliable to the very,
I think, vetted and respectable.
And they have various methods
of securing your currency.
One of them for
yourself is to just
keep it on an air-gapped
hard drive or something
like that, to keep your
digital wallet not connected
to the internet, at least
for the vast majority
of your holdings.
I think to come back
to the first part
of your question, how to get
them, it's actually pretty easy
nowadays.
I mean living in the US, there's
a company called Coinbase.
You just sign up for an account.
You have to verify your
identity the same way
you would for if you're
opening a bank account.
And then you deposit money from
your bank through ACH transfer.
And it takes five days
or something like that.
But once you have the
money in your account,
you can buy the bitcoins.
They also let you
buy ether, which
is the native token of
the Ethereum network.
And they let you buy litecoin,
which was the first alternative
to bitcoin, the first alt
coin, as they call them,
that was created.
So it's fairly easy.
I mean, for more
sophisticated trading,
there are a lot of
exchanges out there online.
They run 24 hours a
day, seven days a week.
I mean, it's really unbelievable
to see these markets in action
because they do not have
opening and closing bells
like the New York Stock Market.
The action is fast and furious
and all around the clock.
And some of them let
you do margin trading.
They let you do market--
I mean, they let you do a lot of
different sophisticated trading
strategies.
Bittrex is one of them.
Bitfinex, Poloniex.
They don't all end in X.
But Bitstamp, GDEX-- there's
a number of them.
But yeah, Coinbase will give
you a kind of simple wallet
and buying and selling
structure all in one.
So--
SPEAKER 1: Great, thank you.
So also in the book
that you highlighted
the growing pains that
comes with getting
started with bitcoin.
Can we talk a
little bit about Mt.
Gox and then so
how pretty much--
BRIAN PATRICK EHA: Sure.
SPEAKER 1: --like--
BRIAN PATRICK EHA: These
are such large questions.
I'm just like, there's
10 different ways
to answer each one of these.
So I'm struggling a little bit.
So Mount--
SPEAKER 1: Well, so I would be
concerned about if you forget
your password, if there
is a hack you can't--
you can never get
your money back.
So I guess I'm just curious to
hear about what has improved
since then, I guess.
BRIAN PATRICK EHA:
Well, I mean, one thing
is don't leave all
of your holdings
on an exchange that's connected
to the internet, right?
So if you've kind of heavily
invested in this stuff,
and you have $50,000
worth of digital currency,
I would encourage you not to
leave all of that in a place.
I mean it might seem great
to have it all on an exchange
that if the price goes up or
down and you want to buy more,
you want to sell
and make a profit,
you can access it instantly.
But if the exchange
is hacked, if they
don't have proper protections,
you do run a risk, right?
SPEAKER 1: Yeah.
BRIAN PATRICK EHA:
So I would encourage
people to maybe
buy on an exchange,
then take most of their
holdings, put them offline.
Make a backup of that wallet.
Many of these wallets
you can get 2FA for.
Some of them have what's
called multisig protection,
where you actually need--
it's like a two of three
kind of thing.
So one person is not able to
access the funds completely
by themselves, which is an
extra layer of protection.
There's a number of
different security
methods, which I honestly find
a little bit boring to talk
about.
But--
SPEAKER 1: No.
[INAUDIBLE]
BRIAN PATRICK EHA: No, no, no.
It's OK.
I'm just kidding.
But Mt.
Gox was the world's
first bitcoin exchange.
These 24-hour online exchanges
I'm talking about, Mt.
Gox was the first one.
It launched in 2010.
It was based in Japan.
And the problem was it
turned out the guy running
it was not very competent.
I remember one of
the former employees
said it was like running
on a spaghetti code base.
It was just kind of messed up.
And to be honest,
they're still untangling
what went wrong there.
But, yeah, either there
was an inside job,
or there were some
pretty catastrophic hacks
that happened.
And it seems like the
CEO might have covered
that up for a
while and basically
let it become
catastrophic, yeah,
the same way that the
collapse of Lehman Brothers
was catastrophic or something
like that because they
hid the problems with their
balance sheet for a long time
until it became impossible
to hide, right, so--
SPEAKER 1: Got it.
BRIAN PATRICK EHA: Yeah.
SPEAKER 1: So I'm curious--
BRIAN PATRICK EHA: But--
SPEAKER 1: --about--
BRIAN PATRICK EHA:
Sorry to interrupt.
I was just going to
say, since those days,
there are a lot more
vetted, more trustworthy,
better-run exchanges out there.
And many of them are regulated.
They have to do AML
and KYC compliance,
just like a lot
of other regulated
financial institutions--
SPEAKER 1: Just know
your customer and just--
BRIAN PATRICK EHA: Right.
Anti-money laundering-- know
your customer and so on.
Some of them are
based in the US.
And they have to comply with a
lot of regulations today, yeah.
SPEAKER 1: Great.
And so how did you first
get involved with bitcoin?
What is it that drew you in?
And I thought it was so funny
that your editor said, oh, this
is a--
BRIAN PATRICK EHA: Oh yeah.
SPEAKER 1: This little
thing, it's a fad.
What was the first sense
that you got that this
could be something really big?
Because you've been researching
this for five-plus years now.
BRIAN PATRICK EHA: Yeah.
Well, like I said, I mean, when
I first encountered bitcoin,
it seemed to me like an
idea whose time had come.
But I didn't know whether it
was really going to become huge
or not.
I thought it had the
potential to become big.
But I think the easy thing would
be to sit here and make myself
Nostradamus and
say, I always knew
it would go up to
$3,000 per bitcoin.
And I always knew there'd be
billions of dollars in venture
capital flowing into the space.
I mean, I didn't
always know that.
What I did know was
that I was looking
at some very smart
guys who were--
their minds were just throwing
off sparks as I talked to them.
And the technology seemed sound.
It seemed like something that
had never existed before.
Some people have
criticized it, saying
it's a solution in
search of a problem.
But I don't really
find that to be true.
From the first time I
heard about it I thought,
wow, this is something that no
one was ever able to do before.
You didn't have
non-counterfeitable digital
cash ever before.
And you didn't have a way to
send money peer to peer across
borders, just without involving
any payments company, any bank,
any third party at all.
I remember one of the things
that stuck out in my mind
in the early days was
when PayPal and others had
instituted a blockade
against WikiLeaks.
They weren't allowing
any of their users
to donate to WikiLeaks
because of some of the things
it had done involving
government secrets.
SPEAKER 1: So the fact--
BRIAN PATRICK EHA: So--
SPEAKER 1: --that they could
control your money like that.
BRIAN PATRICK EHA: Right, right.
SPEAKER 1: That's
the difference here.
BRIAN PATRICK EHA: So
I mean, and that might
be what you call an edge case.
But it is certainly a case.
And it was something
that stuck in my mind
because what people started
doing was donating in bitcoins.
WikiLeaks very quickly started--
they found a way to start
accepting donations in bitcoin.
And people started donating
these digital currencies.
And no one could stop that.
No one could forbid that.
No one can keep you from
sending digital currency
to your grandmother
in Cuba, even
if Trump re-institutes all
of the sanctions against Cuba
and so on.
And I found that to be
really, really fascinating.
SPEAKER 1: Great.
So just one-minute warning.
We'll do one more question.
And then--
BRIAN PATRICK EHA: Sure.
SPEAKER 1: --if everyone could
line up for their questions.
So in all the stories that
were involved in your book,
what is one of your favorites?
What is one that you
enjoyed the most covering?
BRIAN PATRICK EHA: Sure.
Well, there was this
guy named Charlie Shrem.
Some of you might
have heard about him.
He was actually the
CEO of that company
that I first wrote
about for CNN Money.
And he was just a
middle-class guy living
with his parents in Brooklyn
when he heard about bitcoin.
He was like 21 years old.
And partly through
happenstance, partly
through sheer will and
determination and intelligence
and being in the right
place at the right time,
he ended up
co-founding what became
one of the largest,
most significant
of the early bitcoin startups.
It was actually the first to
raise a significant amount
of venture capital.
It raised to $1 and 1/2 million
in the fall of 2012, which
seems like a small
amount of money now.
But like I said, the market
cap of all the bitcoins
in existence back then was
only $100 million or less.
And at one point, this
company was handling 30%
of all bitcoin transactions.
They were flowing
through BitInstant.
And then through-- this is kind
of spoiler alert for the book--
but through some
things he got up to,
he ended up getting charged
by federal prosecutors
and having to spend a
year in federal prison.
And now he's out.
And he's actually working
on a comeback, which I just
wrote about for the July
issue of "Fortune" magazine.
But to me, there's a pathos
there of this middle-class kid
made good and his assent to this
level where he was clearly--
I thought of all
the main characters
I followed in the book, he
was clearly the most gratified
by the attention and
the respect that he
got as a result of his work.
And then his fall
from grace, and then
being kind of disowned by some
of the people he had previously
rubbed shoulders with,
including his investors,
and now being out and
working on a comeback.
So yeah, there's just something
there that I find compelling.
SPEAKER 1: Absolutely.
BRIAN PATRICK EHA: Yeah.
SPEAKER 1: OK, great.
So if any questions
in the audience,
you'd like to come and line
up now, we can get started.
BRIAN PATRICK EHA:
Yeah, I know that was
a bit all over the place.
I'm sorry.
[CHUCKLES]
SPEAKER 1: And so you
have to read the book.
OK, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Hi, my
name is [? Arian. ?]
BRIAN PATRICK EHA: Sure.
AUDIENCE: So the question I had
was following everything that's
been going on, the way
people hold coins in a sense
is like they're holding stock
and not necessarily like they
have a piece of
currency or value.
And I think that's created
a lot of volatility
in the price of
bitcoin, ethereum,
all these other things,
which makes them harder
to use as currencies,
which is what some of them
are meant to be.
What do you think
needs to happen
for that not to be the case?
Because when people
buy real currency--
non-cryptocurrencies-- they're
used a lot more than bitcoin
is.
And some people are
just holding bitcoin
for the sake of holding it.
So I guess the question
is, what do you
think needs to
happen to create more
stability in the cryptocurrency
market versus volatility?
BRIAN PATRICK EHA:
To be honest, I
think there are different
schools of thought
about this, right.
A traditional economist
would look at it
and say, how can these
be currencies when
their value fluctuates so much?
They can't be used as a
stable unit of account,
that basically the
three qualities that
make something a
currency typically
are that it's a store of value,
which bitcoin certainly is.
You're talking about
people trying to use it
as a store of value, right.
It's a unit of exchange,
which bitcoin is.
It can be used to buy goods and
services or sent peer to peer.
But then the third is that
it's a unit of account.
And that is one that bitcoin's
not really used for that today.
And it's partly because
the price is so volatile.
But there's another
school of thought
that says, actually,
the volatility is OK.
The speculation is OK
because before bitcoin
can become a truly global
currency that can really
serve a huge global user base--
and actually it's
worth mentioning
that a month or two ago, a study
out of Cambridge University
found that the number of people
now using cryptocurrencies
worldwide rivals the
population of small countries.
So that's pretty impressive.
But even that, it's not a
giant global user base, right?
But they say right
now the market cap
of bitcoin's in the $30
billions or about $40 billion
or something like that.
Really, its market cap needs
to be much higher, I think,
before it can serve a
truly global user base.
It needs to be maybe
even 10 times higher
when you compare it to
the amount of US dollars
that are out there,
for instance.
So actually, the
speculation is OK.
The fact that some
people are hoarding it
might be OK because if it
makes it more valuable,
if it makes it more scarce,
and that drives the price up,
that might be when we see its
function as a currency start
to really come to the fore.
The other answer
to your question
is that there are actually
technological solutions
to the volatility that allow it
to still be used as a currency.
So for instance,
payment processors who
exists in the bitcoin
industry today,
they are willing to take
on that volatility risk
on behalf of the merchant.
So if you have bitcoins, and
you want to use them to buy
bedsheets or something like
that from Overstock.com--
and they do accept bitcoins--
you will send the
bitcoins to Overstock.
But Overstock actually won't be
exposed to the volatility risk.
They don't handle the
bitcoins themselves.
It gets accepted for them
by their merchant, payment
provider, which I believe
for them is Coinbase,
or it might be a
company called BitPay.
That company then will
exchange the currency for them
almost immediately
and give them the cash
that they want to keep
as their unit of account
for their bookkeeping.
And you're happy because you got
to spend your digital currency
the way you wanted to.
The merchant is happy because
they got the US dollars.
And the merchant
services provider
is happy because they
made a little percentage
on that transaction.
So you know--
AUDIENCE: OK, thank you.
SPEAKER 1: OK.
AUDIENCE: Hey.
I was curious to see what your
thoughts on the flippening are
and where you see, like, the
bitcoin-versus-ethereum debate
going and what maybe the
advantages and disadvantages
of the two are.
BRIAN PATRICK EHA: Yeah, I
mean, so really big question.
What he's talking
about is the idea
that some people
have that ethereum
is going to overtake bitcoin
in terms of its market cap,
in terms of its just
overall use case,
that maybe there aren't
that many things bitcoin can
do that ethereum can't do.
Ethereum right
now is the world's
second-biggest cryptocurrency by
market cap, by number of users,
and so on.
As a journalist, I kind
of cherish the fact
that I can be somewhat
of an observer
and not have to, like,
take a very partisan side
because there are
a lot of partisans
right now in the
cryptocurrency space.
And you can talk to one guy,
and he'll swear up and down
that ethereum is
practically a scam
and that there's no
reason you should
use anything but bitcoin.
And then there are
other people who
say ethereum's more
sophisticated than bitcoin.
And I think they somewhat
have different use cases.
And I do think that bitcoin
today still has an incredibly
strong first mover advantage.
It has an unparalleled network
effect, unparalleled name
recognition.
If I go to the average
person and I say,
have you heard of
bitcoin, they might not
know anything about it.
But they might say, yeah,
that sounds familiar.
But if I say, do you
know what ethereum
is, they're going
to probably say,
I have no idea what
you're talking about.
And frankly, that is one of
the first obstacles ethereum
would have to overcome.
I think we know from
the technology space
that in order for one
service or one product
to overtake a rival one, it
can't just be like 10% better,
right?
It needs to be twice as good or
five times as good sometimes.
And I'm not sure for
most people ethereum
fits those
qualifications right now,
especially, I mean,
bitcoin right now
is having some trouble
scaling the network up
to serve a global user base.
Transactions are taking longer.
They're becoming more
costly and so on.
I mean, the transactions
themselves are instantaneous.
But the time it takes to confirm
the transactions on the network
to verify that they're
valid, that's taking longer.
So some people were
saying, oh yeah,
bitcoin is like becoming
a stick in the mud.
All those people-- the
competing stakeholders
in the bitcoin system--
they can't work out
their differences.
They can't come to
agreement on a proposal
for how to upgrade the
software and move forward
to scale the network.
So obviously, ethereum is
just going to eat its lunch.
But we just this past week saw
some problems with the ethereum
network, where transactions
were getting clogged,
and there were some issues.
So I think that
took the wind out
of the sails of a lot of people
that previously had thought,
like, it's just clear sailing
for ethereum from here on out.
So--
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
BRIAN PATRICK EHA: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Hey, great
to have you here.
BRIAN PATRICK EHA: Sure.
AUDIENCE: Such an astonishing
five years in the crypto world.
And it's all very exciting,
with distributed applications
and so on.
But as you know, Mike
Hearn is probably
the most famous Googler
that advocated for bitcoin
and joined the
bitcoin corp. And he
quit because of infighting
and debates over the direction
that it should take.
Given the amount
of trust that has
to be placed in the developers
for these different coins
and the amount of
infighting that goes on--
BRIAN PATRICK EHA: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: --are we still blocked
on some kind of governance
solution to actually make these
kinds of things successful?
BRIAN PATRICK EHA:
Well, that's where
some of the
alternatives to bitcoin
become potentially interesting.
There's one called Dash,
which some people think
in terms of its innovations
as a form of digital cash
or cryptocurrency or
whatever it might not
be a huge improvement
over bitcoin.
What's really
interesting about it
is its innovation in
the governance model.
So with Dash, basically, the
network kind of administrators,
in a sense, are people
running these things
called master nodes.
And in order to
run a master node,
you have to own at
least 1,000 Dash.
So you have to be very much
a stakeholder in the network.
And then proposals
for doing marketing
for the network, proposals
to upgrade the software,
add new features, or
any number of things--
they all on a monthly
basis get put up for a vote
by all of the people
running master nodes.
Now it's still a
decentralized system.
In fact, many of the people
running master nodes,
it's not even known
who they are exactly.
And one individual could
run, theoretically,
more than one master node.
But there are thousands
of master nodes
right now on the network.
And even the development team
for Dash is actually beholden
to their approval because the
way Dash works is that some
of the new Dash coins-- if
you want to call them that--
that are created every
month, they actually
get allocated as funding
for the developers
to pay the developer
talent and so
on to keep working on
the system, improving it,
and so on.
But they have to
actually propose
to the stakeholders
of the network,
this is what we'd like to do.
And then there's a
democratic process
in which that gets voted on.
And sometimes their
proposals don't pass.
But it's a way to kind of keep
the developers honest and keep
the interests, I think, of
all the different stakeholders
in the network aligned.
The developers rely on
them for their funding.
At the same time,
the stakeholders
rely on the developers in
order to keep the network going
strong, which makes their Dash
coins valuable and incentivizes
them to run the master nodes
in the first place and so on.
So that, to me, is a really
interesting governance model.
I don't know whether Dash
will one day replace bitcoin
for that reason or something.
But people are starting to
innovate, not just on aspects
of the technology itself
but on aspects of the way
that these decentralized
networks are governed.
And yeah, I mean, bitcoin
is very much the 1.0.
It's had to go through
all these growing pains.
And people didn't know
how this stuff would
work until they had to do it.
But as one guy put
it to me recently,
the nice thing
about bitcoin is it
is going through all
these growing pains.
And so it is becoming kind
of more trusted, in a sense,
simply because it has shown its
resilience despite scandals,
despite the hacks of
bitcoin exchanges,
despite some bitcoin
startups failing, and so on.
AUDIENCE: Hey there.
My name's Nick.
BRIAN PATRICK EHA: Hey.
AUDIENCE: So my question's
around the ethereum network
and really the
speculation around moving
to a proof of stakes concept.
BRIAN PATRICK EHA: Mm-hm.
AUDIENCE: So I guess
the question is,
is that what's stopping
big players from entering
the game at that point in
a proof-of-stakes network
or a proof-of-stakes concept
and them taking a large market
share on the computing
power, essentially
removing maybe the concept
of the decentralized network?
Or is that not even
a problem at all?
BRIAN PATRICK EHA:
Well, to be honest,
I'm not as much of an
expert on the underpinnings
of the ethereum network as I--
I don't know quite as much
about the proof-of-stakes system
and how all of that is
handled as I do about, like,
the proof-of-work system
that bitcoin uses.
But yeah, I mean, I think
people do have concerns
that some of the power
in the ethereum network
is already concentrated
in too few hands.
I mean, the fact that the
network forked last year
and essentially split into
two versions-- you have
what they call ethereum, but
it's actually the new ethereum.
And then you have what they
call ethereum classic, which
is the original network.
And that happened because
there was a big hack and theft
of this one investment
vehicle that was running
on the ethereum network.
And millions of dollars worth
of ether were stolen from it.
And so the top leaders
of the ethereum network,
including the guy
mostly credited
as its creator, this guy
named Vitalik Buterin,
they decided, OK, we're
going to roll this back
and make it so that this
thief doesn't profit
from his ill-gotten gains.
But the way to do that
in a blockchain network
is that you basically
have to fork the network.
And if everyone had
agreed, then maybe they
would have all moved
over to the new network.
But some didn't.
And some people
decided to continue
putting developing resources
and time and effort
into the original network.
And so now you have actually two
different networks, one which
has stayed sort of immutable,
and no transactions have ever
been rolled back, and then this
new one that actually today is
much more valuable in
terms of its market cap
but which some people think
is really not so trustworthy
because it's possible that
some of these big stakeholders,
at any time they
don't like something,
they might choose to undo it.
And the only thing, in a sense,
stopping them from doing that--
well, maybe not the only thing.
But the main thing
people are relying on
is they just say,
well, we won't, right?
Another issue that
I have with ethereum
is that I think it's a bit
more of a, I don't want
to say exactly a
cult of personality,
but there is a bit of
a cult of personality
around this guy, Vitalik
Buterin, who's incredibly
young, I mean, clearly
brilliant, I mean,
a real genius, but
this really young guy
who is known as the creator
of it and co-founder of it.
And "Fortune" actually
perpetrated a hoax on Sunday
night that Vitalik
Buterin had died.
And almost instantly, $4
billion were wiped off
the market cap of ethereum
because (CHUCKLING) people
said, you know--
whereas with bitcoin,
the creator--
this guy whose identity is still
not known, Satoshi Nakamoto--
after the first couple of
years of working on the system
alongside other developers
he had recruited,
he walked away and just
vanished into the night.
And bitcoin has continued
to thrive after that.
I think that was one of
the last brilliant things
he did was that he chose to walk
away from it to see if it could
stand on its own, to not let
it be a cult of personality,
to not constantly
have people just going
to him as the Oracle
of Delphi to make
every decision for them.
Ethereum still needs to take
those training wheels off,
in a sense.
And Vitalik has
said, to his credit,
that he'd like to take a
step back at some point.
But that hasn't
really happened yet.
So--
SPEAKER 1: OK.
AUDIENCE: Hey there.
First of all, I love
that [? Noval ?] quote.
So thanks for sharing.
BRIAN PATRICK EHA: Sure.
AUDIENCE: Hoping you can touch
upon your opinion on, like,
the block-size debate
that's currently going on.
BRIAN PATRICK EHA:
Yeah, no, I don't have
a super strong opinion on that.
I mean, it gets
really technical.
And there are these
different competing proposals
for how the network
should be scaled up,
as I said, to meet the needs
of a growing user base.
Basically, transactions--
the reason that it's called
the blockchain network is that
transactions are processed
and put into blocks--
these kind of batches.
And every 10 minutes,
approximately a new block
is created, and it's added
to the existing blockchain.
So you have this
immutable ledger
that records every transaction
going back to January 2009
in this giant
de-centralized ledger
that you can think
of as a chain.
But the problem is
that these blocks only
have a certain capacity.
Each block can only hold a
certain number of transactions.
And as the network has
gotten bigger and bigger,
as there have been more and
more transactions, whether it
be spending it as currency,
or trading activity,
or what have you, those
blocks have been--
they've gotten full, basically.
And although, as I
said, the transactions
themselves are still happening
instantaneously, the time
it's taking for miners
to take new transactions,
confirm them, verify
that they're valid,
and thus add them
to new blocks that
can be added to the overall
blockchain, it's taking longer.
There's been basically
this slowdown.
And so there are
different proposals.
Some people are
saying, well, let's
make the blocks twice as big
as they currently are, OK?
Let's make them four times
as big as they currently are.
Let's do this other thing
and make them twice as
big as they currently are.
And there's all this stuff.
One of the concerns about
making the blocks bigger
is that then the size--
I mean, the data storage size
of the overall blockchain--
will become much, much bigger.
And it will be much harder
for smaller operators
to still participate
in the network, which
could potentially
concentrate power
in fewer hands on the network.
I that's one of the concerns.
And then there are
other concerns,
if you can call them that, like
the fact that the way right
now to get the miners to confirm
your transactions faster if you
really need them to be
confirmed quickly is you
pay them a little mining
fee, a little transaction fee
basically.
Now some people think
this is a real problem.
We have, over the
last couple of years,
we're seeing these
transaction fees get higher.
It used to be that
bitcoin transactions were
almost costless.
And that was one
of their advantages
over things like using
credit cards or other--
Western Union and so on.
But if these transaction fees
are going to keep climbing,
then that seems to
take away at least part
of bitcoin's advantage, right?
But on the other
hand, the mining
pools-- some of the big
mining pools in China,
for instance-- they seem to
like these transaction fees
just fine, for obvious reasons.
And so there is a
bit of a battle.
I mean, there are
some developers,
there some bitcoin
companies, other stakeholders
that have agreed on
certain proposals.
And then there are others that
are holding out against them.
And in many cases,
it's the miners.
And the difficulty there
is that the developers
can create whatever version
of the software they want.
They can all agree, this
is what we need to do.
This is the best
version of the software.
A lot of the bitcoin
entrepreneurs and companies
and investors can agree.
But in order to actually move
to that version of the network,
you need to get at least 51%
of the total processing power
on the network to
agree to start running
that version of the software.
You need a majority to agree.
So that has been if you want
to call it holding back some
of the progress in the network.
On the other hand,
it's kind of great
that you have a system that
can't be easily changed, right?
It's almost like the political
system of the United States,
that sometimes the
gridlock is not a bug.
It's a feature because otherwise
each new administration
that comes in could
just completely
undo everything and just
wipe the slate clean, right?
So this is one of the
potential advantages
of new cryptocurrencies
is that they
might be a little more nimble.
They might be more agile.
They might have better
governance systems
in some sense.
But it could be
that bitcoin will
take on this elder statesman
role, where it, out of all
these assets, it becomes
the most stable and trusted,
the one that's least
subject to change.
And it might turn out
to be a little bit
of a tortoise compared to
the hare of the others.
But sometimes you
want a tortoise.
So--
SPEAKER 1: All right.
Well, thank you.
BRIAN PATRICK EHA: Yeah.
SPEAKER 1: So we're
running out of time.
If you still have questions,
you can meet us over
by the book-signing table.
And then we can still
take them over there.
Thank you so much, Brian.
BRIAN PATRICK EHA: Sure.
SPEAKER 1: Thank
you for coming in.
BRIAN PATRICK EHA: Yeah.
SPEAKER 1: Thank you.
BRIAN PATRICK EHA: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER 1: All right.
Great.
[INAUDIBLE]